hello everyone welcome back to PJ's Tech
class what we did last week was making
the prong and the basic shape of the
ring so let me turn on what we had last
time and let me turn this off all right
so this is what we have left from last
time let's go to the ghost view today
what we like to do is continue to build
the be setting all the way around this
ring shank let's get started for this
engagement ring model party we would
like to have the small stone for a one
point two millimeter how to make this
stone you can look at my previous video
a right top corner with the info I come
over there now you can find that video
or go to my channel you will find the
video for how to make a diamond alright
for easier for us to snap on a lot of
things because this is um this is a mesh
and it's hard to snip out a lot of
things so I usually will do the command
it's called mesh online and for mesh
online you click on any of the mesh he
entered and it will give you the outline
for exactly what you are looking from
the view in this case it's the top view
so I kind of give it some sort of around
its shape it's easier for us to snap on
things
next we are going to make those little
beads you can do is using the pipe
creating the curve and using the pipe on
it or you can use the cylinder in
federal agency so under this time I'm
going to snapping into the end point
this is a one point two millimeter so
I'm going to use the radius four point
two five which is diameter four point
five point two point two five
and how long do you need it you
definitely need it
you can have the be long enough to get
it into the ring shank but not over the
ring shank all right so we wanted this
be a little bit higher so we can your
jeweler were able to set it you also
don't want it to be too cutting into too
much all right
and then so let's go ahead to fill it
ages this one I'm going to use the foot
edges it's living right here and then
let's choose point to fall it's a little
bit smaller than our diameter so it will
have a nice surface right and then let's
imagine that we're going to have this
stone roughly about here the best
distance is you will have it about point
one to point one five millimeter okay
and then so what we are going to have
let's say if we have a stone right here
and our prong which is going to share
this it's going roughly about right
there alright so that look nice to me
what I'm going to do now is if the prong
look nice where whatever the position is
you're going to use that to me row to
the other side and use that to mirror
to the bottom all right so the goal is
we are going to do is having those
products let me group them temporary and
then we are going to almost setting more
like this way right and they will
continue follow the ring shank so that's
the ideal
we are going to do right so let's go
ahead then turn on the ring shank and
let me move our stone to the side so
it's easier to see okay so take a look
on the perspective view all right so the
goal is we need to have a stone place
over there for the first one and flow
along the B curve right but we need to
find a curve first so we need to find
the center of this the curve on the
center of this surface right the command
you're going to use under the curve you
have curve from the object and you also
have the the one for extract I so curve
all right it will pick up the surface
right now you see this a line going on
moving while my mouse is moving
I want to snapping into the quadrant now
if you s happen go in this direction all
you need to do is go to the command bar
right here star go you can toggle it
back to different direction right so I
want to snap into the quadrant where
it's right in the middle and the reason
it doesn't go all the way to it doesn't
go all the way to the other sides
because last week we split this ring
shank in half in order to get rid of the
surface right there on the besides me
part of the ring chain so now we have
the half of it and all we need to do is
kind of mirror it to the other side
it's gonna type in zero and mirror there
right so once this mirror I'm just going
to join them
let me turn them in to the other color
shows easier to see so now that right
color curve is right there so I'll go is
going to be an underneath that line
I'll go is going to be a wrench this guy
we have to look at all three different
view I'm holding the shift so they will
turn in ninety degree and I'm gonna send
them right there right we kind of need
to follow the curve so I'm going to make
them sit a little bit lower there
alright and then to do the D flow
alright one thing I haven't do is we
need to make the color but I just want
you to see how it how it goes before we
actually go ahead and make the color
right we need to make sure that is close
to the center all right so let's give a
try before we actually making the cutter
for you for easier for modeling are
usually in this in the area I will turn
down the record history and then we'll
go into the transform and then we'll go
to array and you have along the curve
okay so the sub the object you're going
to array is offset enter and then you
hit this curve it will X you how many
you want and I was trying for
twenty-three let's try it one more time
so you have the stone flow all the way
around and they kind of not line up
that's why you need to turn on the
history because what you can do is you
can kind of move this up a little bit
and then so let's take on the right view
so make sure they won't know why right
so right after you get that you probably
don't need the very bottom one so you
can do is it's to delete that one all
right so we know 23 will work so that
will work on one side however if you
send this one it really depends on the
size of the stone if you sit on this one
sometimes you may see happen is the
stone is really dark so usually we want
to punch a hole behind a stone right so
we kind of need to make a color so I'm
going to redo redo all the way back to
the center all right okay so how are we
going to make the cutter the the two
reason you want to make a cutter first
is going to make your storm look
brighter second reason is easier for the
strong setting so if you already pre pre
make a seat
all right so we have this right here I'm
going to move it higher than my girdle
and I kind of holding I'm going to drag
it and holding the control then you are
creating a surface there all right all
right this is not a very good surface I
should do this way
okay we need to starting from this point
let me go to the top because the line
that I draw if you zooming is actually a
lot of point and we want to reduce the
point for half a better model so I'm
going to do is to draw a circle and our
diameter was one point two millimeter
okay so I have that curve I'm going to
use that curve and bring it up a little
bit over the girdle okay all right so
let's go to the perspective view I'm
going to move this down with the gumbo
the blue arrow and then hold my control
and you can see a ghost line there and
what it does is you are creating a
surface okay so let me do again I'm
going to move it down an arrow to
somewhere it's just a little bit of
below the girdle and hold my control
then I creating that surface okay and
I'm also going to put the top right at
the center and with that dot I want to
move it close to the bottom of my stone
so we are going to use the surface tool
you have one is from extruded from the
curve to the point right so the curve we
want to extrude is the h of that surface
we just made and you will go to snapping
to the point all right so now we have
this one
and also this one we are going to join
them and also cap them so they will be
solid I'm kind of turning into the red
color alright so this is a cutting tool
that is follow the button of the ring
shank I'm sorry but I love this stone
and we're also going to make a cylinder
snapping to the point as well the
cylinder is going to cut through the
meadow that is sitting on the top of it
usually you want to do is about 50% so
I'm kind of eyeball like how big is it
and I want to make it longer so I will
have definitely have a nut go through
the ring shank right now I'm going to do
is bowling those two holding unit those
two all right so now this is the whole
set that we are going to flow right let
me move this one we no longer need the
curve I'm just gonna did it then alright
so I'm going to group them and move it
to move it you know on the side and turn
on my ring shank alright so let's go
back to what we were doing almost I
think this is I could the same alright
so we're gonna go into the front view
move this one here coming here coming
here alright and let's take a look my
ISO curve is disappear so let's do go to
the curve curve from the object and you
have extra iso curve I'm going to
extract that one to make sure snapping
to the quadrant you can extract one more
time snapping to the quadrant that will
work too and then pick up both curve and
then you wanted to join them
so we are going to use this one
that's move it to almost the middle and
bring in a little bit
that's enlarge this one and you want to
make sure that they follow the surface
okay and then we're gonna use the same
comment turn on a history we call
history
I will go to transform and then you have
array and then you have a rate along
curve so let's start we already picked
the object and let's pick deep path we
were using 23 so we're gonna use 23
again all right so that's what I mean
that all the red part which is your
cutting tool will be longer than the
shank alright so let's move make sure
that we have even number not even number
even looking on the shank I'm gonna move
this one just go up a little bit and
make sure that they align all right now
on the very bottom one ungroup them we
don't need this one we don't need this
one and we still need the rest of it
okay now you're looking really good and
that's don't forget to ungroup them what
we need to do now is we need to trim
them or polling DIF them so what I like
to do is to mirror all of them to the
other side
okay and then we want to use the
bullying difference that's bullying
difference from the ring to all the red
part
let's do have first if your computer is
not super strong you have so many
different small part in my crashes so
let's do the bullying difference on one
side it will say the polling difference
will break the history because we have
history which is fine all right so now
we have that one and then we are going
to bowling difference again with this
okay
all right so now we have the stone on it
and you also need to bowling the little
prong to the ring shank let's take a
look on the head let me do it this one
alright so this is how we arrange the
stone on it and sometimes if it is
getting too close you might need to move
before you bowling your money to move
them in a little bit on the top
individually alright this is the
engagement ring with a six prong head
and be setting on the ring shank I hope
you'll like it please like and comment
and share my video that really helped me
ranking it's really hard to continue
without your support thank you very much
I will see you next Monday
[Music]